>>> IS IT AN APOLOGY TOUR OR
PUBLICITY TOUR?
WILL SMITH HAS A NEW MOVIE OUT
BUT HE IS EXPRESSING IRS REGRET
EXPLAINING HIS RAGE AND
DESCRIBING WHAT DROVE HIM TO
SLAP CHRIS ROCK AT THE OSCARS.
>> THAT WAS A HORRIFIC NIGHT AS
YOU CAN IMAGINE.
YOU KNOW, THERE'S MANY NUANCES
AND COMPLEXITIES TO IT, YOU
KNOW.
BUT AT THE END OF THE DAY I
JUST -- I LOST IT.
>> CNN ENTERTAINMENT REPORTER
CHLOE IS WITH US NOW.
HE CAN'T PUT IT TO BED.
HE HAS A NEW MOVIE COMING OUT.
>> NOR SHOULD HE.
THERE ARE STILL SO MANY
QUESTIONS LEFT UNANSWERED, ANA
AND ALTHOUGH THIS IS HIS FIRST
LATE NIGHT SHOW APPEARANCE, YOU
KNOW, SINCE THE INFAMOUS OSCAR
SLAP, WE STILL DON'T HAVE MUCH
MORE INFORMATION AND WE STILL
HAVE NEVER HEARD FROM CHRIS ROCK
WHO HAS NOT RESPONDED TO CNN'S
REQUEST FOR COMMENTS.
HERE'S MORE OF WHAT WILL SMITH
TOLD TREVOR NOAH LAST NIGHT.
>> IT WAS A LOT OF THINGS.
IT WAS THE LITTLE BOY THAT
WATCHED HIS FATHER BEAT UP HIS
MOTHER, YOU KNOW.
IT'S, YOU KNOW, ALL OF THAT JUST
BUBBLED UP IN THAT MOMENT, YOU
KNOW.
I JUST -- THAT'S NOT WHO I WANT
TO BE.
>> RIGHT.
>> YOU'VE KNOWN ME FOR A LONG
TIME SO YOU KNOW ME PERSONALLY
SO YOU KNOW, BUT, YOU KNOW,
Y'ALL MIGHT NOT KNOW.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> SO HE SAYS THAT THAT'S NOT
WHO HE WANTS TO BE NOR WHAT HE
WANTS HIS LEGACY TO BE
REMEMBERED FOR, ANA BUT STILL
DOESN'T EXPLAIN EXACTLY WHY,
WHAT CAUSED HIM TO RUSH THE
STAGE AND WAS IT REALLY JUST
WHAT CHRIS ROCK SAID ABOUT JADA.
WAS IT YEARS AND SO HIS MARRIAGE
BEING MADE FUN OF, SOMETHING
THAT TREVOR NOAH BROUGHT UP LAST
NIGHT.
WE DON'T HAVE ANSWERS.
I THINK AT SOME POINT HE'S BEING
TIGHT-LIPPED AND I IMAGINE THERE
WILL BE A BIG SIT-DOWN AT SOME
POINT BUT LIKE YOU SAID IN YOUR
INTRO, THERE IS A MOVIE TO
PROMOTE, OKAY, "EMANCIPATION"
COMES OUT NEXT WEEK ON APPLE, A
MASSIVE MOVIE GETTING A LOT OF
AWARD SHOW BUZZ BUT WILL SMITH
ALTHOUGH ELIGIBLE 0 WIN AN OSCAR
COULDN'T GO TO THE OSCARS TO
ACCEPT IT OR ATTEND THE CEREMONY
IF HE'S NOMINATED.
>> FEELS LIKE HE'S 4HOLDING BAC
AND HAVING A TOUGH TIME
ANSWERING THOSE, THANKS, CHLOE
I WONDER WHAT YOU THOUGHT ABOUT
THAT AND THEN I'LL SHARE A
LITTLE PERSONAL STORY.
WHAT DID YOU THINK?
>> I WANT TO HEAR THE STORY
FIRST, BUT I WANT TO GIVE A
LITTLE CONTEXT TO THIS, THAT
JUST BECAUSE OF THE SEGMENT WE
WERE LAST TALKING ABOUT, HE'S
CURRENTLY PROMOTING A FILM.
THE FILM DOES TAKE PLACE IN SORT
OF A SLAVERY ERA.
AND THERE IS ACTUALLY A KIND OF
WIDER CRITICAL MOVEMENT OF BLACK
TRAUMA ON SCREEN.
WHICH MAKES THIS FILM JUST A
TINY BIT MORE OF A HEAVY LIFT TO
PROMOTE.
THE AUDIENCE YOU WANT TO DRAW TO
IT MAY BE A LITTLE BIT UPSET
WITH WILL SMITH RIGHT NOW.
THE BLACK AUDIENCE YOU MAY WANT
TO BRING TO IT MAY FEEL FATIGUED
BY EVEN THE CONCEPT OF THE FILM.
SO THE FACT THAT HE'S OUT HERE
DOING THIS EMOTIONAL LABOR
PUBLICLY REALLY DOES TALK ABOUT
THE STAKES OF KIND OF THIS GENRE
OF WORK AND THE BLACK ARTISTS
WHO ARE STILL DOING IT, AND ARE
FINDING IT TO BE LITERALLY A
SELL.
>> YOU KNOW I KNOW WILL SMITH,
AND HAVE BEEN IN COMMUNICATION
WITH HIM OVER -- SINCE IT
HAPPENED.
I MEAN, BEEN COMMUNICATING WITH
HIM BEFORE, BUT SINCE IT HAD
HAPPENED, WE'VE BEEN TALKING AND
I MET WITH HIM AND SMOKE WITH
H
-- SPOKE WITH HIM AN HOUR ME
AND HIM TALKING.
NOT TO BETRAY CONFIDENCE BUT
WHAT HE SAID ON "THE DAILY SHOW"
IS PRETTY CLOSE TO WHAT WE
TALKED ABOUT, AND IT HAS BEEN A
JOURNEY FOR HIM OVER THE LAST
MONTHS AND I FEEL LIKE HE IS
SOMEWHAT OF A DIFFERENT PERSON,
AND I'M SURE HE WILL SHARE THAT
WHEN HE'S READY TO SHARE THAT,
HE WILL SHARE IT.
I AGREE WITH YOU, IT'S GOING TO
BE A HEAVY LIFT AND I KNOW THAT
HE'S --
>> I'M NOT SAYING THAT TO BE SO
FOCUSED ON THE BUSINESS PART OF
IT.
I THINK HE HAS BEEN APOLOGIZING
IN THE ERA OF CRUMMY APOLOGIES,
THIS IS WHAT APOLOGIZING DOES
LOOK LIKE.
THE QUESTION IS NOW, WHAT DOES
IT MEAN TO RE-EMBRACE SOMEONE OF
THIS STATURE CULTURALLY?
WE'VE SEEN IT IN OTHER CONTEXT,
METOO, ET CETERA, WHERE IT GETS
KIND OF COMPLICATED HOW PEOPLE
FEEL ABOUT THE PERSON'S ART.
THIS IS NOT THAT, BUT IT IS ON
THAT SAME KIND OF SPECTRUM OF
THE APOLOGY, WHAT HAPPENS AFTER
THE APOLOGY, WHAT DOES IT MEAN
TO BE FORGIVEN IN THE CULTURAL
SENSE OF IT.
>> CAN HE BE RE-EMBRACED?
THAT'S THE QUESTION?
CAN HE BE RE-EMBRACED.
>> TBDA.
>> IT WILL NOT BE FROM A LACK OF
TRYING.